[Music]
what's inside that church what happens
to those people
[Music]
[Applause]
Jason he's dead
[Music]
Jase I feel I feel really good
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we must be getting close hope nothing
goes wrong I'm just a drop in land in
the middle of a German squad or
something's gonna go wrong we both know
what the Nazis are gonna do to a guy
named Rose and Jeff is gonna go wrong
[Music]
reach up with the light chels
[Music]
[Music]
see you on the ground
[Music]
not even the feet of
[Music]
[Music]
in the car
the thing that I love the most about the
movie was that it took a sort of classic
World War 2 adventure movie and it
smashed it into sort of monster horror
film oh it starts as a straight war
movie
and expects a really interesting turn
and you add on this mad crazy horror
element do an experiment Solomon there
and things become very terrifying and
intense there are things that happen
that are odd and off we don't quite know
exactly what they are what is this
four thousand you hire these thousand
year soldiers we are all just doing our
best to above all else get the mission
done with these dire circumstances that
they weren't expecting to encounter and
so I think there are a lot of surprises
in there
beside the church crowds brandy as soon
as I hit the ground they said the church
how did you get inside the church
dead bodies slowly sitting down with
experiments on the minute they're doing
experiments on the villagers why just
like her on burning people with these
flamethrowers and they're still moving
the bodies cocoons in the tree did you
get eyes metallic compound she's missing
she doesn't have a body and she's still
she's still talking and I saw those a
boys hey did you get eyes on the tower
compound it's that's Howard basin yeah
it's below the ground but there's more
than that damn you okay look
[Music]
what the hell is that
three months ago I was cutting grass in
my front yard a mailman shows up with a
letter from the howl of me now I'm here
no idea of one when end up
welcome to France
what happened here some questions don't
have good answers
[Music]
there's a lot of soldiers out there
there's only formas
my dad was inside that compound
what is this 1,000 year army these
thousand years soldiers
[Music]
[Music]
what's not yet
what do you do with those people they
have been given that purpose
[Music]
[Music]